microsoft est une mission spatiale qui
vise à tester le principe liga valence
alors qu'est ce que le principe
d'équivalence donc c'est le principe
fondateur de la théorie d'invités
générale d'einstein qui dit que tous les
corps quel que soit leur masse ou leurs
compositions vont chuter de la même
façon ils vont être accélérés la même
manière en principe violence et de dire
qui à équivalence entre accélération et
gravité
l'expérience microscope on fait appel un
satellite c'est une expérience à bord
d'un satellite
le premier challenge ça a été de
réaliser un satellite qui soit avec un
environnement suffisamment calme pour
instrument qui est extrêmement sensible
donc l'onera a réalisé un instrument sur
mesure pour cette expérience et le
challenge était de réaliser un
instrument qui est aux limites de
performance de tout ce qui se réalise
aujourd'hui
donc en termes de mécanique ou internes
d'électronique normalement aux limites
de l'état de l'art et de pouvoir
assembler tout ça grâce à une équipe qui
a intégré puis qui j'ai dit rien rallye
toutes ces compétences électronique
mécanique physique dans la même équipe
au même endroit on a pu construire un
instrument complexe et une mission
complexe puisque on avait aussi la
capacité à définir une mission c deja à
définir ce que serait cette mission
comme on a utilisé sa petite
la durée des missions ces deux ans
pendant ces deux ans va y avoir des
carrières des clipse grosso modo trois
mois par an au fond on va être un
satellite
donc on va avoir trop son mono 18 mois
pendant lesquels on va pouvoir faire des
expériences lensois butaient du principe
violence dans le vérifie que
l'accélération de de masse soit
identique dans un mouvement dans une
trajectoire autre date air et puis on va
faire d'autres expériences pour essayer
de d'estimé certains paramètres
instrumentaux ou du syndic par exemple
savoir est ce que nos deux masses qui
sont bien centrer ou à combien elles
sont centrées donc on va faire des
mouvements sur cette île pour y signer
ses centrales
et puis on va faire aussi estimé le
l'alignement d'un tassement par rapport
aux censeurs des toiles qui sert de
référence est donc pareil on va faire
aussi les satellites hier regarder le
lac ces rations induites sur
l'instrument suivant les différents
actes déduire l'alignement de notre
instrument par rapport aux 100 sur les
trolls
c'est vraiment une expérience physique
fondamentale donc ce qu'on cherche à
faire c'est donner vu par l'expérience
un certain nombre de valeurs aux
théoriciens qui leur permettent de
régler leurs théories